KELSEY HIGHTOWER: So I'm
going to start from the bottom
and build a weather
application from zero,
starting with the database all
the way up to the end point.
Now, we only have
about 15 minutes.
So we're going to see if we
can get this all done in time.
So the first thing
we want to do is kind
of start with this example.
So here's a terminal.
Everyone like terminals.
Is that cool?
[CHEERING]
Someone was like,
where's my GUI?
We'll get there.
All right, so what I
want to do is maybe
start with a few
weather locations.
So these are all of
our regions in the US,
our newest region being
Los Angeles, California.
And the goal is I want
to take these names
and get weather data.
Now, here's the problem--
I can't just give these
names to the Weather Service.
I actually have to give
them geocoordinates.
Now, I have a couple
of options here.
I can actually use the Maps API.
So the Google
Cloud Maps platform
does provide a
Places API that can
trade those names in and
get back some coordinates
or something close.
And then once I have
those, I can actually
send those to the weather.gov
and actually get back
coordinates.
But here's the thing.
I don't have a lot of time
to write all this code.
Now, once you become
a senior engineer,
I'm going to teach you
a couple of tricks.
Now, this is what all
senior engineers do.
You guys ready for
the first pro tip?
Now, you've got to
write some code.
Now, this is what we do.
You do this.
Have you ever heard
of Stack Overflow?
[LAUGHTER]
You have no clue
what's going on.
All right, so let's do this--
Google Maps platform.
Like this is high-quality
code that you
can find on this thing, man.
Trust me.
Then we'll do weather.
And then, OK, let's go here.
All right, how do we do this?
Oh, code-- this looks legit.
All right.
I'm not sure who this Terence
Ryan guy is, but you know.
[CHEERING]
Now, this is the internet.
So what you got to do is you
got to scan for those security
vulnerabilities.
You've got to make sure
this stuff is legit.
Hold on.
Let's make sure
we can grab this.
Let's see what we're
going to do here.
So let's grab this code.
Come on, I don't
care about cookies.
[LAUGHTER]
It's the internet.
How dangerous could it be?
[LAUGHS] Where's
my copy and paste?
Like, why are they
trying to sell me stuff?
I'm trying to get my job done.
Oh, come on.
Like, the hardest part of this--
all right, look at this, ads.
All right, we should
be in business now.
So let's grab this.
So what you want
to do is you want
to scan for security
vulnerabilities
as you go through this.
That looks legit.
Talking to a database--
sure, why not.
Cool.
Let's just grab that.
So here's the thing,
oh, I didn't grab it?
Golly, I should be fired.
[LAUGHTER]
This is why we use GIST.
All right, copy-- so one thing
is good programmers copy.
Great programmers paste.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
So we got our code.
Now the next thing we need
to do is set up a database.
Now, I am the world's
most average DBA.
So for me, I'm going to use
a hosted database service,
and I like to keep
it open source.
So my favorite
database is Postgres.
And what I'm going to do here,
listen, if you're a developer
and you need to
set up a database,
there is no shame in
clicking the button--
click Database,
bam, like a pro, OK?
You got to own it.
[LAUGHS]
So I got this database set
up, and I created a user.
I actually do not know
how to create a user,
so I usually click this
button because I have
to look it up all the time.
So once I have the user created,
I have a little EMV file
so I can use natural tools.
So the thing I like about this
I can use my existing tools
to do my job.
So the first thing
we want to do here
is [INAUDIBLE] get the
environment variables
for my connection string
in my environment.
And then we're
going to see if we
can connect to the actual
database, and I can.
Let's make sure we don't
have any tables set up
so we're starting from scratch.
Now the next thing I need
to do is actually set up
the database schema, right?
SQL is dope, by the way.
If you don't know SQL,
you should learn it.
So psql, and then
we're going to run
this create database command.
Uh-oh, we need to get our
credentials-- so pg.emv,
and then let's do this.
And then-- come on.
Uh-oh.
We got a database schema.
And let's make sure we don't
have any data in there.
We're starting from scratch.
So the next thing
we're going to do
is we're going to change
into that directory
where we've downloaded
that production-ready code
from the internet.
And what we're
going to do is we're
going to give it credentials.
So this should be cool, legit.
This guy is a nice
guy, I'm pretty sure.
So I'm going to put those
credentials in my environment.
And then what we want to do
now is just do something local.
So when I build code,
I like to test locally.
I do not develop in a container.
I test things on
my local machine.
So here what I want to
do is do a quick build.
And I'm using the new vgo
stuff so I can actually
do development work
without using a Go path.
So for me, I'm
writing everything
in [? Go link. ?] And
then what I want to do
is just build the application.
Ooh, and it compiles.
That's legit.
So let's try it.
Let's see what we can do.
So remember, the goal is
we're going to take locations.
And we want to trade them for
geocoordinates so we can then
talk to the Weather Service.
So let's try that now.
So we'll do weather data.
Oh, it looks like
it's working, right?
So look it, this is like
science, geocoordinates.
And then we're getting
the weather data.
So if everything is legit, we
should be able to do a query.
And we have the weather
data in our database.
So we're in business.
[APPLAUSE]
Now that we got
our weather data,
we need somewhere to
actually run our code.
And also, if you have the
idea of running this command
from your laptop in
production every day,
that's not how you do it.
You might want to run this
code in a cluster somewhere.
So we need some infrastructure.
So the next thing you do is
we need a Kubernetes cluster.
There's no other place better to
run your code than Kubernetes.
Marketing-- I've done my job.
All right.
[LAUGHS] So here's a
Kuberentes cluster.
But there's something
interesting here.
So there's a couple of
tricks that I like to do.
Here's my Kubernetes cluster.
One thing you can do
that's really nice in GCP,
you can actually have
multiple node pools.
So this is the 1.10.5 cluster.
I have 13 nodes here.
But I actually have
those nodes split
between two
different node pools.
Now, the reason
why I'm doing this
is I'm using the first general
pool for my web apps, my batch
jobs, long-running services.
But this other node pool,
I'm a big fan of Envoy.
So you've been hearing
a lot about it Istio.
But underneath Istio there's
this nice reverse proxy
called Envoy.
And Envoy, if you
can think about it,
is like a cloud
native replacement
for Nginx or HAProxy.
It has all these
things that I need
to do things like rate limiting
and timeouts and retries.
But I like to actually run
Envoy as my edge load balancer,
even in GCP.
It's the same load balancer
I run on my laptops,
so I want some parity.
So what I'm doing
is I'm actually
running each of
my Envoy instances
across these three nodes using
what we call a daemon set.
And then the last thing I do
to set up my infrastructure?
I create a load balancer that
points to just those three
machines.
So if you think about it,
I have a network appliance
running inside of my cluster--
no extra hops, no IP
tables, straight to Envoy,
then directly to my apps.
So with the
infrastructure in place,
we can start to think
about deploying our code.
So let's go back to the
command line really quickly.
So the next thing
I want to do is
I don't want to execute
this from my machine.
So here's a cronjob.
Every five minutes it's
going to kick that code off
for me automatically.
So my goal is just to
push this cronjob up.
But remember, the price
of admission to Kubernetes
is a container image.
Here's my second trick
that I like to do.
I have this saying, don't
ship build environments.
Ship artifacts.
So when I built my
containers, I actually
just build my binaries
locally, upload the artifacts,
and only have Docker
package it in an image
with the scratch base image.
So my images, roughly,
are about 7 megs.
And then watch how fast the
builds are if I do it this way.
So the first thing
I'm going to do
is build that application
locally, take that binary,
push it up to
Google Cloud Build.
And Cloud Builder's going
to do all the work for me.
You'll notice
another thing here.
I don't have Docker
installed on my machine.
I can just push my builds
there and get all of my images.
So in just a few seconds
we'll have a container image.
We're ready to go.
And then we can actually
use that cronjob,
and Kubernetes will
keep it running.
kubectl apply dash F cron.yaml.
So you'll notice there will
be no pods created until we
hit that five minute mark.
But we'll start watching just
to see when things come up.
So in about five minutes you'll
see the cronjob kick off.
And Kubernetes will
keep a few of them
around just in case I
need to troubleshoot.
So the next thing
we're going to do is--
we're going to move a
little bit faster now--
is I need to put an
API in front of this.
So what I would do here is
say kubectl apply dash F.
And I have this
Weather API service.
And then what I'm going to
do here is just deploy that.
And that's going to be a little
bit faster because I want it
right now.
I already have the image
on the container registry,
just going to pull
that into the cluster,
and that's going
to start running.
Now, here's the next cool
thing that you can do in GKE.
We've done a lot of work to
make pods first class citizens
inside of Google Cloud.
So you'll notice here
every pod in Kubernetes
gets its own IP address.
Now, the one thing
that we do is we
make those IPs native using a
technology we call IP aliases.
And what IP aliases
does, it takes
all of those container
IPs and makes
them first class in my VPC.
So my development box is
a VM inside of my VPC.
So what I should be
able to do is actually
without any port
forwarding or extra hops,
I should be to make a call to my
API service using the container
IP.
And look at that--
directly talking
to the container
using a very natural
development flow, where
I can work on another
app while talking to
apps inside of the cluster.
That's pretty dope, if
you didn't think so.
[APPLAUSE]
All right, so we're
moving along here.
The next thing we want to
do is get a web front end.
Again, you kind of establish
some patterns here.
Build a container, push it
up, and describe to Kubernetes
what you want to do.
So here we'll build
our weather front end.
And then we'll do
this deployment.
Now, here's where things get
a little bit interesting.
We're not going to run one copy.
We're going to let
Kubernetes run three copies
across that cluster for us.
Now, once all of
this is running,
I have Envoy in a preconfigured
IP and a DNS address
that's pointing to this
particular back end.
So what I'm going to
do now is pull this up.
And we should be able to
hit the weather back end.
Oh, things are looking good.
Let's see.
All right.
Everything seems to be working.
Now here's the thing--
I've been the sole
developer this whole time.
I know the front end
talks to the API server.
And the API server
talks to the database.
But what happens is someone
else on your team needs
to check things out?
The nice thing is I've
been using OpenCensus.
So again, I don't actually
have a service match.
But you can adopt all these
technologies a la cart.
So if you want to add
tracing to your application,
you can bring in tools
like the OpenCensus library
that allows you to decorate
your function calls
or calls between apps and
send that data to tools
like Zipkin or Jaeger.
In my case, I'm
using Google Cloud,
so we're going to send
it's a Stackdriver Trace.
I'm going to pop over here
to the tracing console.
And then we're going to find
one of those recent traces.
So we can see one that just
came in roughly around now.
And we'll click on it.
And you can actually
see the end to end.
Traffic comes into the
front end, the API.
And then the API returns but not
before talking to the database.
Now, here's a nice thing--
if you trace this inside
of your code base,
and I click Show Events,
I can come down here
and see the exact
SQL query that's
being executed at
that particular hop.
Now, that gives you the ability
to actually see what's going on
and give people a lot more
insight without checking out
the code.
So we got all the
patterns in place--
infrastructure, tracing.
And now we need to think
about something new.
Now, we only have
about five minutes
left so we're going to
have to simulate this.
This is-- when your boss
shows up and is like, hey,
we need some new functionality.
Can you get it done
by Friday, right?
So the task is on.
So we have this infrastructure.
We got this nice pattern set up.
And what we want
to do now is start
to think about something
cool we can add in.
We've got a web front end.
But that's like so 2017.
You got to have a voice
integration with your app
if you want to be cool.
If you can't talk
to your application,
you're probably doing it wrong.
So what we want to do
is think about a tool
called Dialogue Flow.
You're not going to build your
own natural language processing
system from scratch.
Some of you are probably trying.
There's a better way.
So we're going to
use Dialogue Flow.
So again, let's walk to
the pattern really quickly.
We're going to write
the application.
And then we're going to
build it and push it up.
Now, remember, the
container image
is just the price of admission.
So we'll build this up.
Now, here's the
other thing-- you
won't be the sole developer
working on this application
forever.
Maybe there's someone
else on the team
that wants to contribute.
And maybe they have no
interest in writing YAML files
or using Kubernetes
from the command line.
We've done a lot of work to make
sure that Kubernetes works well
from the UI.
So we'll come over here.
We'll go to the
Kubernetes console.
And we can click on Workloads.
Now, notice here, all the
things I did on the command line
are reflected in
the GKE console.
Now, if I have a new
person on the team that's
not quite familiar
with Kubernetes,
this could be their workflow.
We'll click Deploy.
And we've done
something special here.
We've integrated deeply with
GCP, including the Google
Container Registry.
So if I click on
this, I can drop down
to find that image
that I just created.
It finds all the right tags.
Hit Select, and
then it fills out
everything I need underneath.
Let's give this a name.
We'll call it the
Weather Assistant.
We have the right labels.
And if I have
multiple clusters, I
can choose where
I should deploy.
Now, if you want to see what's
going on under the hood,
you can actually display
that sweet, sweet YAML
that you love so much.
[LAUGHS] And then we also give
you an autoscaler to make sure
you can respond to
traffic changes.
And we'll hit Deploy.
So that's going to do all
the heavy lifting for me
right through the UI.
And just like that,
it should be deployed.
We'll switch over
here, and we can
see the Weather Assistant is
now ready, serving traffic.
Now, the next thing
we're going to do
is make sure that we're ready
by checking the health check.
So here's the DNS name
that I've assigned
to this particular app.
We'll hit it.
We see everything is working.
And we can also see all my
track is flowing through Envoy.
I should be in good shape.
So we only have a
few minutes left.
Let's see if we can pull
this last piece off.
So I want to log into the
Dialogue Flow console.
This is also part of the
Google Cloud Platform.
So Dialogue Flow allows you to
design these voice integrations
with your application.
So we'll come here.
There's a couple of
things we need to do.
First, we need to make sure
that our users have a good time
with our application.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to define all
this verified inputs
and create a few synonyms,
just in case they
want to say things like
Los Angeles or Los Angeles,
California, USA to talk
to the weather app.
The next thing we're going to
do is describe their intent.
What does our user want to do?
So here we want to have
them check the temperature.
Now, there's no way
I'm going to define
everything or every
phrase our users would do.
So here what I'm going to
do is give Dialogue Flow
a few training phrases.
And notice how it's
automatically pulling out
those regions that match the
entities that I described
before.
So we're ready to go.
Now I want to send this our web
hub that we just got deployed.
So we'll come here.
We have a couple of more steps.
We'll go to Fulfillment.
And from Fulfillment
you'll see that I'm just
putting in that same URL that
I had earlier that's pointing
to my Kubernetes stack.
You have all kind of
integrations that you can do.
But this time we just want
to do the Google Assistant.
Now, this whole time I've
been using my Pixelbook
to do this demo.
And this is something
I also think
a part of the end-to-end
experience at Google.
So we want to test out this.
Now, I could use the simulator,
or I can actually come down
here and use my laptop.
Now, to prove that
this is real, we're
going to look at the
logs for the assistant
to make sure Kelsey
isn't cheating.
So kutectl logs, we'll give
it that container name.
And we just stream
the logs here.
So we can see it's listening,
but there's nothing there yet.
So if I hit the Assistant
button on my Pixelbook,
we should be able
to talk this thing.
Yeah, whatever.
All right, talk to the
local Weather Service.
WEATHER ASSISTANT APP: Sure.
Here's the test version
of local weather.
Hello, Kelsey.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: Hello.
WEATHER ASSISTANT
APP: Looks like you
have a pretty large crowd here.
I hope the demo gods
are on your side.
[LAUGHTER]
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: I hope so too.
All right, so let's
give this a go.
What's the current temperature
in Los Angeles, California?
WEATHER ASSISTANT APP:
The current temperature
in Los Angeles, California,
USA is 82 degrees Fahrenheit.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: Thank you.
WEATHER ASSISTANT APP: OK.
I've got to admit,
that was pretty dope.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]